Impfen, dazu möchte ich
heute mal etwas sagen,
worüber Wissenschaftler
nicht so oft sprechen.
Deswegen bitte ich euch,
wenn ihr dieses Video schaut,
schaut es bitte bis zum Ende.
Nehmt euch die 10 Minuten,
es ist echt wichtig.
Es gibt wohl wenig,
was dazu noch nicht gesagt wurde.
Das impfen Leben rettet, dass es
nichts mit Autismus zu tun hat,
dass impfen keine persönliche,
sondern eine eine gesellschaftliche
Entscheidung ist,
weil es Menschen gibt,
die aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
nicht geimpft werden können,
und darauf angewiesen sind,
dass wir es tun.
Bla, bla, bla.
Ich weiß leider
zu viel über kognitive Verzerrung,
als dass ich versuchen würde,
dieselben Argumente
immer zu wiederholen.
Denn wenn die Wissenschaft
eine Sache klar gezeigt hat,
dann ist es, dass wir Menschen
immer auf unserer Meinung beharren.
Deswegen will ich heute
einen anderen Aspekt ansprechen.
Aber zuerst, lasst uns
etwas common ground schaffen.
Ein beängstigendes Argument ist, dass
uns Big Pharma alle in der Hand hat.
Und dass die Pharmaindustrie
einfach nur Big Money machen möchte.
Dass sie uns Impfungen unterjubelt,
damit sie schön
Impfstoffe verkaufen kann.
Kein dummes Argument.
Die Sache ist die, dass diese Firmen
genauso viel Geld machen würden,
wenn sie uns
der Natur überlassen würden.
D.h., mit der Behandlung von
Krankheiten, statt mit Vorbeugung.
Und das nicht nur
mit ein paar Spritzen,
sondern ggf.
mit jahrelanger Behandlung.
Es sei denn, Impfungen wirken
gar nicht, oder noch schlimmer,
sie machen uns krank.
Und das ist, ich kann es nicht
anders sagen, einfach nur Bullshit.
Ich kann auf sämtliche Quellen
verweisen, steht in der Infobox.
Aber wenn ihr nicht glaubt,
dass impfen wirksam ist,
braucht ihr dieses Video
auch nicht weiter zu schauen.
Dann kann ich nichts sagen,
was euch aus eurem confirmation bias
rausholen wird.
Wir sind uns einig,
dass Impfungen wirken, ja.
Das ist der common ground,
von dem ich ausgehe,
sonst weiß ich nicht,
wo ich anfangen soll.
Man kann von der Wirkung
von Impfungen überzeugt sein,
aber was ist mit den Nebenwirkungen?
Wie sehen die Risiken
tatsächlich aus?
Genau über die Risiken
möchte ich heute ehrlich sprechen.
Denn es gibt Probleme.
Fangen wir
mit dem berühmtesten Risiko an.
Das Impfungen Autismus hervorrufen,
geht auf eine
gefälschte Studie zurück
von Andrew Wakefield
aus dem Jahre 1998.
Als herauskam,
dass die Studie gefälscht war,
wurde sie wenige Jahre
später zurückgezogen.
Seine Zulassung als Arzt
wurde ihm schnell entzogen.
Diese falschen Aussagen
halten sich so hartnäckig,
weil die Ursachen für Autismus
bis heute nicht geklärt sind.
Einen anderen Fall
gab es 2009 in Finnland.
Wo nach einer Grippeimpfung
60 Kinder und Jugendliche
an Narkolepsie erkranken.
Narkolepsie
ist eine seltene Krankheit,
wo die Betroffenen plötzlich
von Schlafanfällen übermannt werden.
Bis heute sind echte kausale
Zusammenhänge zwischen Narkolepsie
und der Impfung
immer noch nicht bekannt.
Gleich gehe ich
auf mehr Beispiele ein,
aber zuerst müssen wir uns die
allgemeine Statistik anschauen.
Soweit sie nachvollziehbar ist.
Ich weiß,
es ist ein bisschen trocken,
aber Statistik ist
bei dem Thema impfen so wichtig.
Bei der Risikobestimmung
von Impfstoffen unterscheidet man
zwischen häufigen, gelegentlichen
und seltenen Nebenwirkungen.
Häufige Nebenwirkungen sind Rötungen,
Schwellungen und Schmerzen
beim Einstichbereich, leichtes
Fieber, seltener auch Übelkeit.
Gelegentliche Nebenwirkungen sind
hohes Fieber oder Fieberkrämpfe.
Bei der MMR-Impfung z.B. tritt
das in 1 von 3000 Fällen auf.
Seltene Nebenwirkungen sind z.B.
schwere allergische Reaktionen.
Die treten aber nur
in 1 von 1 Mio. Fällen auf.
Bei diesen seltenen Nebenwirkungen
wird es jetzt echt schwierig.
Z.B. gibt es einen Zusammenhang
zwischen der Rotavirusimpfung
und einer Intussuszeption, einer
schmerzhaften Einstülpung des Darms.
Vorläufige Daten verweisen hier
auf ein Risiko von 1:100.000,
doch das Gesamtrisiko ist ehrlich
gesagt nicht so leicht einzuschätzen.
Genau genommen gibt es
zwei große Probleme. Erstens:
um echte Zusammenhänge als Ursache-
Wirkung Beziehung festzustellen,
müssen gut kontrollierte
randomisierte Langzeitstudien
durchgeführt werden.
Wenn eine Nebenwirkung in
1 von 1000 Fällen auftritt,
kann man das mit entsprechend
großer Teilnehmerzahl
in einer Studie nachvollziehen.
Wenn jetzt aber eine Nebenwirkung
in 1 von 100.000 Fällen auftritt,
fehlt den Wissenschaftlern
einfach die statistische Manpower.
Man müsste so viele Daten erheben,
wie es in einer normalen Studie
kaum möglich ist.
Man müsste man Daten
aus der Bevölkerung sammeln.
Und hier kommen wir
zum zweiten Problem.
Seltene Nebenwirkungen
kann man nur feststellen,
wenn sie in der Anwendung auftreten.
Impfstoffe unterliegen strengen
Regulierungen und Kontrollen.
Bis zu der Zulassung
ist es ein langer Weg.
Aber selbst nach der Zulassung
verbleiben noch Ungewissheiten.
Um verlässliche Rückschlüsse
zu ziehen,
müsste man weltweite
kontrollierte Studien durchführen,
mit Hundertausenden
bis hin zu Millionen Menschen.
Die Daten von so vielen Menschen
zu sammeln,
und sinnvoll auszuwerten,
ist schon eine Herausforderung.
Aber eins muss man sich klarmachen:
bevor ein Impfstoff zugelassen wird,
kommt man erst recht nicht
an so große Daten.
Zusammengefasst.
Problem 1:
Für seltene Nebenwirkungen braucht
man unglaublich viele Daten.
Problem zwei:
An solche großen Datenmengen
kommt man, wenn überhaupt,
erst nach der Zulassung,
also in der Anwendung.
Hier kommen wir
zu einem dritten Problem.
Ich laufe Gefahr, dass ich in diesem
Video dieses 3. Problem anfeuere.
Nämlich die Angst der Bevölkerung.
Forschung dauert einfach lange.
Aber die Bevölkerung
möchte natürlich schnelle Lösungen.
Beispiel: 2007 wurde
ein neuer Impfstoff eingesetzt.
Ein MMRV Impfstoff, d.h., eine Kombi
für Masern, Mumps, Röteln
und Windpocken.
Damit man nur einmal
gepiekst werden muss.
Dann fanden Forscher heraus, dass
die Kombi-Impfung bei Kleinkindern
häufiger Fieberkrämpfe ausgelöst,
als die separaten Impfungen.
Daraufhin nahm
die Impfkommission der USA
ihre Empfehlung für den
Kombi-Wirkstoff wieder zurück.
Doch dann stellte sich heraus,
dass die Kombi-Impfung
pro 2300 Impfungen gerade mal
einen Fieberkrampf mehr auslöst,
als die separaten Impfungen.
Anderes Beispiel:
2011 starben in Japan vier Kinder
nach einer Impfung gegen
Pneumokokken und einen Grippevirus.
Die japanischen Behörden stoppten
sofort beide Impfstoffe.
Später stellte sich heraus,
dass es keinen Zusammenhang
zwischen den Todesfällen
und den Impfstoffen gab.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass die
Behörden vorschnell handelten.
Das haben sie nicht.
Sie haben genau richtig gehandelt.
Das Problem ist, dass solche,
sehr seltenen Vorfälle,
inzwischen sehr starke
mediale Aufmerksamkeit bekommen
und die Menschen, nachvollziehbarer
Weise, Angst bekommen.
Nur, wann immer sich herausstellt,
dass ein Impfstoff doch nicht
so schlimm ist wie befürchtet,
kriegt das kein Mensch mit.
Die Angst und die Skepsis ist das,
was für immer bleibt.
Weil die Forschung bei solchen
seltenen Fällen so schwierig ist,
entsteht leicht der Eindruck,
dass Wissenschaftler
entweder nicht fähig sind,
oder schlecht kontrollierte
Impfstoffe auf den Markt bringen,
oder Probleme vertuschen,
deren Lösungen
eigentlich ganz einfach sind.
Aber Risiken sind
nur eine Seite der Medaille.
Man muss immer Risiken
gegen Wirkungen abwägen.
Wie immer im Leben.
Ich steige auch in ein Flugzeug,
obwohl ich weiß, dass Flugzeuge
durchaus abstürzen können.
Selbst, wenn ich z.B.
Angst vorm Fliegen habe,
bekomme ich mit jeder erfolgreichen
Landung das Gefühl,
Puh, geschafft.
Nur beim impfen denkt man nicht:
Geil, heute mal wieder
keine Masern bekommen.
Sollte man aber vielleicht.
Denn die Abwägung zwischen Wirkung
und Risiken wird sehr schwierig,
wenn man ständig von den Risiken hört
aber nie von der Wirkung.
Die Ironie ist, die Vorteile
sind deshalb nicht sichtbar,
weil Impfungen eben so wirksam sind.
Wir können uns heute gar nichts
mehr vorstellen unter Masern
oder Polio.
Der Erfolg der Impfungen tritt sich
also selbst in den Hintern.
Anstatt Angst vor ernstzunehmenden
Krankheiten zu haben,
die wir heute dank Impfungen
zum Glück nicht mehr sehen,
bekommen wir Angst vor viel
selteneren Nebenwirkungen,
nur weil die immer
in den Medien auftauchen.
Weil Wissenschaftler ernsthafte
Probleme damit haben,
solchen seltenen Nebenwirkungen
nachzugehen,
fühlt man sich als sorgende Mutter
schnell im Stich gelassen.
Wenn erstmal eine Sorge besteht,
gibt es für Wissenschaftler und
Behören fast keinen guten Weg mehr,
da raus zu kommen.
Zum Beispiel Thiomersal.
Ein Quecksilber haltiges
Konservierungsmittel,
das bei Impfungen
eingesetzt wird.
So sieht das aus.
Das ist kein reines Quecksilber.
Es ist eine Quecksilberverbindung,
die weniger gefährlich ist,
als reines Quecksilber.
Und für die Mengen,
in denen es zugelassen ist,
besteht auch kein Risikoverdacht.
Aber trotzdem gibt es inzwischen
Thiomersalfreie Impfstoffe,
auf die jeder zurückgreifen kann,
der sich damit nicht wohl fühlt.
Und jetzt fragen die
Leute natürlich:
Wenn das angeblich nicht so schlimm
ist, warum hat man das rausgenommen?
Hätte man keine Alternative geboten,
würden andere wieder sagen:
Die Pharmaindustrie will uns
mit Quecksilber vergiften.
Die harte Wahrheit ist:
Wenn ihr 100-prozentige Sicherheit
bei Impfstoffen haben wollt,
dann werdet ihr sie niemals haben.
Eine 100-prozentige Sicherheit
wird es niemals geben.
All die Probleme,
die ich heute aufgezählt habe,
sind Probleme der Datenerhebung,
die nur bei sehr seltenen
Nebenwirkungen auftreten.
Deshalb habe ich persönlich
keine Angst vorm Impfen,
weil ich weiß, dass die Risiken
im Vergleich zu den Wirkungen
verschwindend gering sind.
So trocken Statistik ist,
die Statistik
ist wirklich essenziell wichtig,
um Impfen richtig zu verstehen.
Z.B. ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
1:100.000 kleiner,
als die Wahrscheinlichkeit
in Deutschland
in einem Verkehrsunfall
zu sterben.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
1:1000.000. ist kleiner,
als sie Wahrscheinlichkeit
einen Sechser im Lotto zu gewinnen.
Bevor es Impfungen gab,
musste jede Mutter, jeder Vater,
Angst haben, dass ihr Kind
an Polio erkrankt,
an Diphtherie stirbt,
manchmal sogar an Masern.
Das ist es, wovor
wir Angst haben müssten.
Und wie gesagt, impfen ist
keine persönliche Entscheidung.
Etwas, dass man mit
sich selbst ausmachen kann
und selbst die Konsequenzen trägt.
Nein.
Mit jeder Impfung,
die ein gesunder Mensch ablehnt,
gefährden wir das Leben von,
v.a. Babys und Kindern,
deren Immunsystem zu schwach ist,
um geimpft zu werden.
Wenn ihr Gutes tun wollt,
teilt dieses Video.
Und schreibt mir,
was ihr denkt.
Schönschlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2017)